مهاجر مجري مع شهاده جامعيه وخبرات بمهن
متواضعه هكذا وصل جورج روس الى الولايات
المتحده قبل نحو 67 عاما لكنه اليوم احد
المستثمرين الاكثر نجاحا في التاريخ
الامريكي وذو شخصيه اعتباريه وثروه تقدر
بسته مليارات وسبعمائه مليون دولار فما سر
هذه الثروه ولد جورج سوروس بالمجر عام
1930 وعاش ويلات الاحتلال النازي قبل ان
ينتقل الى لندن في عام
1947 حيث درس في النهار وعمل بالليل بمهن
متواضعه كحمال في محطات السكك الحديديه
ونادل بملهى ليلي وبائع درس سروس الفلسفه
على يد كال بوبر في كليه لندن للاقتصاد
لكنه تخلى عن خططه بان يصبح فيلسوفا وعمل
في بنك لندن التجاري قبل ان خلال نيويورك
ويبني اسما كخبيرا بسوق الاسهم في عام
1963 اصبح سروس نائب رئيس بنك ارنولد اند
اسبودر واسس صندوق تحوط كبير ثم استفاد من
ارباحه لبدء صندوق التحوط الخاص به قبل ان
يتحول لصندوق كوانتم ويقوم بمضارباته
الناجحه التي كان ابرزها في سبتمبر عام
1992 حيث استفاد من انخفاض قيمه الجنيه
الاسترليني ليجني ربحا بنحو مليار دولار
وهي المناوره التي اكسبته لقب الرجل الذي
حطم بنك انجلترا لم تنجح مضاربات سوروس
دائما ففي عام
1994 تعرض صندوقه لخسائر بمئات الملايين
في يوم واحد لخطئه في توقع ارتفاع قيمه
الدولار مقابل الين الياباني كما اتهم
بالتورط في هجمات المضاربه على البات
التايلن عام
1997 وارتبط اسمه بالازمه الماليه التي
اجتاحت اسيا في العام التالي فيما كان قد
خسر فعليا المليارات نتيجه هذه الازمه قبل
ان يستعيد صندوقه عافيه في عام
1999 بفضل مكاسب سوق اسهم الانترنت في عام
2000 اصبح سروس اكثر تحفظا في اعقاب
انهيار فقاعه التكنولوجيا ثم قرر في عام
2011 التوقف عن اداره اموال المستثمرين
الخارجيين والاكتفاء بالتعامل مع اصول
واملاك عائلته بعد ذلك
ركز سوروس الذي لقب احيانا بسروس المضارب
على الاعمال الخيريه من خلال مؤسساته
وشراكاته مع المؤسسات الاخرى في اكثر من
120 دوله حيث يقدم المنح الدراسيه ويدعم
جهود فلسفه المجتمعات المنفتحه التي قادها
معلمه ليعود الى الفلسفه بعد ان تخلى عنها
لجمع الثروه
[موسيقى]